[Music]
that's New York Democratic Congressman
Jamal Bowman arguing with Kentucky
Republican Thomas Massey over how to
stop school shootings like the one in
Nashville that left three students and
three adults dead it's understandable
that tempers flare and voices rise in
the aftermath of such horrific events
when faced with such situations the urge
to do something to do anything is nearly
impossible to resist but is Congressman
Bowman right that more guns lead to more
deaths the short answer is no over the
past few decades the number of guns in
America has increased massively so much
so that there are now more guns than
people in the United States yet federal
crime statistics say that firearm
homicides dropped about 40 percent
between 1993 and 2018. for other crimes
involving guns the decline was 71
violent crime did Spike during covet and
while the most recent data is incomplete
it's clear that gun-related violence
remains far below where it was 30 years
ago despite more guns than ever being
out there that's great news especially
since reducing the number of guns in
circulation presents not just immense
pragmatic challenges but almost
certainly in Super Bowl constitutional
barriers when it comes to schools the
2020-2021 Academic Year the latest for
which full data is available did see the
highest number of school shootings with
casualties this Century thankfully there
are too few violent deaths to generate
statistically significant conclusions
but the long-term trends show no
increase in homicides or suicides among
students staff and teachers overall
schools are becoming safer and safer
with the government finding that between
2009 and 2020 non-fatal crime rates
dropped for students ages 12 to 18 from
51 to 11 seven victimizations per 1000
students what about Congressman Massey's
contention
[Music]
he appears to be correct though contrary
to his claim that there's never been an
accidental weapons discharged by a
teacher a January 2023 Rand Corporation
study found that teachers have indeed
been involved in accidental discharges
of weapons on the larger question of
arming teachers Rand simply says there
isn't good enough data on whether doing
so would increase gun violence or reduce
it across eight categories such as
stopping mass shootings or preventing
suicides what then is to be done most
schools are already gun-free zones or
have strict controls on who's allowed to
carry while on campus many have armed
officers on campus despite no evidence
that such a presence deters violence
recent school shootings like the one
last year in Uvaldi Texas where law
enforcement officials not only did
nothing to prevent an active shooter but
restrained parents trying to rescue
their children underscore that police
need better and more effective training
the 2018 school shooting at Marjory
Stoneman Doug Bliss High School in
Florida highlighted how many red flags
School staff police and social workers
had ignored it's deeply unsatisfying to
Simply say that the people in charge of
school safety need to do better but it
might be the best option especially if
they're rushed to do something means
trying something that we already know is
impossible ineffective or both
[Music]